un
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
petit détail
vous fait plonger dans la mémoire
traumatique et vous êtes de nouveau à 10
ans à 13 ans
[Musique]
on est submergé et ça c'est
pourri la vie même des décennies après
véronique à 60 ans mais parfois elle
revit le traumatisme de son adolescence
de cette époque elle a brûlé toutes les
photos elle n'a gardé que celle de son
enfance à nancy jusqu'à sa communion
avant que tout ne commence
s'apprête était vraiment très sympa tout
le monde avait bien moi j'aimerais bien
en fait toute la famille était un peu
comme sous l'emprise de ce prêtre est ce
qui fait que les abus se faisait même à
la fin des repas j'étais sur ses genoux
elle touchait est en fait devant tout le
monde et personne ne réagisse et
et puis après c'était plus loin
évidemment des attouchements sexuels
et surtout répétitif
j'ai eu l'impression d'être abandonnés
par mes parents parce que quand j'ai
essayé de leur dire ce qui s'est passé
ben
réguler quoi et on m'a pas soutenu on
m'a pas cru on perd on perd confiance en
soi on perd confiance dans les autres
aussi on n'a plus les repères qu'est ce
qui est bien qu est-ce qui est pas bien
[Musique]
cette histoire véronique la raconter à
la sias la commission indépendante sur
les abus sexuels dans l'église son
rapport qui décrit un phénomène de
violence massif et systémiques a été un
séisme pour les catholiques comme le
montre cette réaction de l'évêque
d'orléans au lendemain de la remise des
conclusions je suis vraiment sous le
choc de deux voilà de ses 330 mille
victimes voilà c'est dit c'est une ronde
d'ailleurs face et je sais pas j'ai tous
les sentiments qui m'animent de monde de
colère de et puis en même temps de dire
ben voilà on n'a pas su c'est toute
cette décennie on n'a pas su protéger
les enfants et les personnes qui nous
étaient confiées
monseigneur blaquart a déjà été
confronté à ce type d'affaires la
principale concernant son prédécesseur
andré fort en 2018 ce dernier avait été
jugé coupable de ne pas avoir dénoncé
les actes pédophiles commis par pierre
de castellet un ancien prêtre du loiret
condamné à deux ans de prison ferme
à l'époque le diocèse d'orléans avait
déjà lancé plusieurs dispositifs pour
lutter contre les abus sexuels sur
mineurs
depuis la conférence des évêques de
france à lourdes en novembre 2021 il
tente d'en créer de nouveaux avec les
autres diocèses en suivant les
recommandations du rapport
un rapport et des préconisations que
vient expliqué alice casa grande l'une
des membres de la sias lors d'une soirée
organisée à orléans début février par
ailleurs présidente de la commission de
lutte contre la maltraitance cette
catholique est encore bouleversée par
les auditions
c'était une expérience vécue la sienne
avant d'être des chiffres mais avant
d'être des propositions mais c'est
d'abord une traversée et pour ce qui le
concerne a fallu un certain temps avant
de se relever
puisqu'à chaque fois que j'allais à
l'église le dimanche je voyais des
fantômes et à chaque fois que
j'entendais un enfant chanter je me
disais ah oui bah c'est ça c'est une
imagerie ses victimes
allez ce caza grande participent
désormais à l'une des deux nouvelles
commissions destinées à apporter
reconnaissance et réparation aux
victimes de prêtres et de religieux et
les premiers dossiers affluent
la première chose que les victimes dans
cet argent c'est absolument pas ça la
première chose que les personnes
victimes ou nous ont demandé c'est la
justice c'est-à-dire la reconnaissance
des faits les noms les lieux les dates
dites le que ça s'est passé et que
c'était pas moi et ensuite pour
certaines il ya des demandes
d'indemnisation c'est pas du tout la
seule réalité
présente pour échanger avec alice casa
grande véronique combien demander une
compensation financière pas pour elle
mais pour ses enfants nos enfants nous
ont souffert indirectement de ce que
j'ai vécu comme air de famille j'étais
pas libres de les élever
par exemple de laisser facilement aller
chez des amis ou bien être allé en
voiture avec quelqu'un d'autre c'était
pour moi je vois là et je voudrais que
ce soit libre d'élever leurs enfants
comme ils veulent
pour indemniser les victimes comme
véronique tous les diocèses ont
participé à un fonds de secours et de
lutte contre les abus sur mineurs
baptisé sellam pour un total de 20
millions de roses derrière ce n'est pas
l'église qui va étudier les demandes
mais l'une des instances de réparation
ça peut être fait que par des
professionnels et nous ne sommes pas du
tout qui est à l'intérieur du diocèse a
donc on va prévenir toutes les personnes
qui ont pris contact avec nous que cette
instance existe s'il faut pouvoir
appeler les accompagner sa soeur on peut
leur donner un coup de main mais c'est
bien l'instance qui va les recevoir
écoutez leurs besoins leurs attentes
écouter les attentes écouter les
victimes tout court et les croire
au delà de la reconnaissance
une autre recommandation de la sias et
de généraliser les protocoles pour que
les diocèses signale toute dénonciation
d'abus sexuels à la justice celui
d'orléans a été l'un des premiers à le
faire il ya un an ils signent désormais
un partenariat unique en france avec
l'association d'aidé aux victimes du
loiret avait elle le tort qu'on a eu
cette pensée qu'on pouvons qu on
pourrait résoudre
les situations
par nous mêmes avaient bon avec l'aide
quand même je suis pas de
badens d'un psychologue qu'on connaît
d'un avocat mais non on a besoin
aujourd'hui de travailler vraiment
ensemble au sein de cette saucisse de la
société française quand
pour véronique présente à la signature
comme membre de l'association diocésaine
cette étape est une victoire
pour moi c'est un moment très important
que j'attends depuis longtemps c'est à
dire vraiment à un engagement qui sort
de l'entretoit de l'église catholique
pour s'appuyer sur les compétences des
personnes du civil
désormais les victimes qui appelleront
la cellule d'écouté du diocèse pourront
être prises en charge par ha vl
l'association repart d'ailleurs ce jour
là avec deux dossiers oui elle et elle
est angoissée elle est stressée elle a
plein de questions
mais ce qui rend cette convention unique
c'est la création d'un outil
criminologique adapté à l'église pour
aider les responsables du diocèse à
repérer les comportements à risque par
exemple dans ce qu'on appelle en
criminologie dans ce modèle la
personnalité antisociale ça va par
exemple être une personne qui ne va pas
vouloir se mêler aux autres pour les
réunions qui va un petit peu
allez bille en tête dans son idée ça
c'est des personnes qui en groupe du
coup vont avoir tendance à s'isoler et
du coup si elles sont isolées avec un
groupe de mineurs mais non la yaris qui
en fait
censé prévenir les abus sexuels cet
outil va s'enrichir avec le temps
on va pas tout révolutionner la par
contre il ya peut-être aussi des
précautions à prendre
lorsque des bénévoles souhaitent
intégrer le diocèse non dans le cadre du
recrutement il va falloir aller vérifier
des points et ça fait aussi partie des
évolutions sur lesquels on travaille
comment eux apprendre à se gérer en
interne et prévenir aussi de l'arrivée
de certaines personnes qui peuvent être
nocives
ou un avantage
le diocèse d'orléans et prescripteurs
dans la lutte contre la pédocriminalité
mais après 70 ans de silence est il
encore possible de parler et de
pardonner c'est la question posée dans
une pièce de théâtre présentée mi mars
dans une église d'orléans intitulé
pardon elle est écrite et jouée par
laurent martinez il y raconte son
traumatisme
j'ai été violée par un prêtre quand
j'avais 8 ans
c'est le l'aumônier de l'école lui
déboutonne mon pantalon
et le fait glisser jusqu'aux genoux
lui baissent monthly
lui penche la tête et me prend dans sa
bouche
mais que fait-il
j'ai peur
c'est là où s'ancrent en fait le
traumatise parce qu'après on se met en
place des schémas mentaux
dont on ne sait pas se défaire
d'appréhension par exemple après
d'appréhension la relation sexuelle
répartie tu viens avec moi dans la
chambre
des traumatismes qui font écho à ceux de
véronique elle a travaillé à la venue de
cette pièce qui aide à briser le silence
je suis très touché que j'avais beaucoup
de personnes ce soir parce que
d'ailleurs une personne a dit j'ai pas
pu en parler dans la paroisse et là on
peut en parler voilà donc en fait c'est
ça
oui c'est encore douloureux sur ces 2 16
et quand même difficile de leur parler
donc ce soir c'est c'est un bon pas en
avant
lors d'un temps d'échangé avec le public
l'évêque d'orléans est d'ailleurs
interpellé sur cette question de
libération de la parole et d'écouté mais
c'est vrai que cette écoute donc
pourquoi elle est difficile
parce que ça vient toucher à notre rêve
sur l'église
on le quand même entre nous
voilà qu'ils ont peu sur un piédestal et
puis cela ramène ça l'a fait descendre
mais je crois qu'il faut parler et il
faut surtout voilà jeu
merci beaucoup à la banque est là
surtout dégoûté écoutez écoutez
écoutez oui mais pour ensuite agir c'est
la priorité pour véronique et laurent
l'urgence elle est là et ses missions
une urgence absolue est de passer au
chiffre zéro donc ok on a non pas un
wagon de retard mais plutôt une centaine
de trains de retard mais il faut arrêter
de se flageller par rapport à ça
aujourd'hui on sait quelles sont les
actions qui sont à mener donc en avant
quoi en avant mais le plus dur dans tout
ça c'est de mobiliser tout le monde de
mobiliser tous les évêques et il est là
le travail à faire aujourd'hui
pour l'instant tous ne se mobilise pas
de la même façon et beaucoup observent
ce que fait orléans le rapport de l'
acia a certes été un électrochoc mais
l'église n'engagera réellement sa
transformation qu'à une condition mettre
les victimes au coeur de la réforme
le péché de l'église a été très grand et
voilà et mai mais je crois que ce que
nous avons vécu ces derniers mois
est beau et moi me donne plein
d'espérance mais le fait qu'on ait la
pièce ça aurait été impensable d'avoir
cette pièce il ya
deux ans
[Musique]
on sait qu'il n'ya jamais rien d'acquis
on sait qu'on ne préviendra pas de tout
on sait qu'
il ya des situations patron à côté mais
ça c'est la vie donc il faut aussi
accepter maintenant l'idée c'est
vraiment de limiter au maximum les
risques
[Musique]
j'ai dû faire le deuil de la maman que
j'aurais mais l'était être de l'épousé
que j'aurais aimé être du travail que
j'aurais aimé faire mais maintenant
parce que sans doute eiffel j'ai fait ce
deuil est ce que j'aurais pu être 100
sans ce drame et est du coup petit à
petit je suis plus librement moi même
pour être qui je suis
et quand on a été un objet dans les
mains d'un autre pour son propre plaisir
et bien devenir soi-même bassée
c'est une telle victoire
ce